for some sports gamblers betting on the
super bowl coin toss is about as good as
the odds can get but for jim mackinville
the houston furniture mogul known as
mattress mac putting down multi-million
dollar bets on big games is actually a
win-win move
for years mackenville who owns the
three-story chain gallery furniture has
made headline-grabbing wagers as
sensible hedges against his big sales
promotions during big events like the
super bowl march madness or the world
series mack will place a giant bet on
one team and offer customers a full
refund if they win for example during
this year's ncaa men's basketball
tournament mattress mac bet 5.5 million
dollars on the kansas jayhawks and ran a
promotion to refund anyone who spent
three thousand dollars or more on
certain types of mattresses and
furniture if they won which they did the
promotions and beds have helped
mackenville grow the business which he
started with his wife linda in 1981. in
2019 gallery furniture had 164 million
dollars in revenue and by the end of
last year sales grew by about 40
to more than 230 million dollars the
economics of mackinville's strategy has
mostly paid off
during his march madness promotion he
bet a total of 9.86 million dollars
across four bets and won 13.5 million
dollars
gallery furniture sold a total of 12.9
million dollars during that time and
after refunding all of his customers he
had over five hundred thousand dollars
in profit
mattress mac says the promotions also
attract a deep pocketed and more
credit-worthy clientele during the super
bowl customers spent an average of 5 800
and during march madness the business
brought in 842 new customers and
1234 repeat customers
the new ones spent an average of six
thousand seven hundred and sixty four
dollars and the repeats spent an average
of five thousand eight hundred and
eighty two dollars
the percentage of customers who get
approved for in-store financing also
jumps about 10 during sports sales
events but these wagers have not always
been smooth
in 2014 mattress max suffered his
biggest loss when he offered a promotion
that would give customers whatever they
bought for free if the denver broncos
beat the seattle seahawks in that year's
super bowl he did not hedge the
promotion with anything and when seattle
won the business was out nine million
dollars
in the years since he's learned to
always hedge his big sales with a giant
bet and he'll also wager more if sales
are surpassing his potential win total
[Music]
you